- Dumped a bunch of crap in a blender
- Yeah.
- And blend it.
- Wait, it's blended too?
(bass beat music)
- I have never had a
Frappuccino, not once.
- I have never had a Frappuccino,
which I know a lot of
people think is weird,
but I don't drink coffee.
- I never had any type of coffee
except for black coffee in my entire life.
- I have never had a Frappuccino
nor have I ever had any
coffee flavored anything
or I guess coffee itself,
it's never appealed to me.
- I always see them doing the pumps.
When I go in there, I'm just like,
hi, can I just get like
a small black coffee?
- I'm trying something
for the first time that
everyone else has had so,
yeah I'm a little nervous.
- I don't even know
what's in a Frappuccino.
- Actually, I just looked up on Wikipedia
(laughing) the ingredients
of Frappuccinos.
- I assume it's just a
milkshake with coffee in it.
- Does it make you poop
like regular coffee does?
(laughing)
- It makes you poop?
- Yeah, coffee does,
I just (blowing) just
a flood gates open up.
- Why have I not experienced something ...
- Really?
- That it seems like all of
American has experienced.
- I'm kind of proud never
having one, I'm just like ...
- Well now we're gonna ruin it.
- Here it comes,
Oh are they different flavors?
I've never even had
like, cold coffee before.
- What?
- Lady and the Tramp style.
- Yeah.
- You go left, I go right.
- Let's do this.
(gasp)
- It's got a strong coffee
aftertaste that I'm not in to
but like the initial taste
was kind of like a chocolaty treat.
- It's pretty sweet, I
feel like, the first ...
It's like a Pepsi.
- That initial sip, you're
just like ya know what
this is not bad and then
it just kinda coats your tongue and
your like alright, I
kinda want to stop now.
- It's still sitting with me right now.
- You can't really taste the coffee
which I'm disappointed about.
I feel like this is a good thing for kids
to get into coffee with.
- Oh my God.
It's green.
- It looks like it would be healthy
because it's green.
- I honestly didn't know
that you could get a
Frappuccino without coffee.
So, right now my mind's blown.
- That was a big sip.
- It tastes like a green tea Kit Kat.
- It's not bad, I don't know,
it kinda tastes a little minty.
- That's very like tea.
- Tasting pretty good, should I get,
(laughing)
I guess I'll do another one.
- It's delicious, it's
like a green tea milkshake.
- Can I finish this though?
- This one looks dangerous.
- I feel like now this is
a drink off the kids menu.
- Look at that form, perfect.
- This feels like straight sugar to me,
but I love it.
- Actually, this is not that bad.
- You like it?
- I really do.
- Cherry, strawberry flavor
that's very like, thick.
- Then that cream just
like, hits you like a train.
- It's like strawberry milk
with a bunch of sugar in it I guess
and I always liked
strawberry milk as a kid.
- It tastes like a those
old Nestle Quik milkshakes.
- The strawberry Nestle Quik milkshake.
- Yes.
- I could probably down this
in three sips if I wanted to.
- After going my whole life without
ever having a Frappuccino
and then now having one
yeah, the mystery is gone.
The veil has been lifted.
- Right.
- I've seen the wizard.
- I had no idea Frappuccinos were cold.
- But maybe in the future,
I'd have a sip of one of
my friend's Frappuccinos.
- I'm going to stick with black coffee.
I feel, I feel Frapp'ed out.
- If I was like, having a bad day
I would order it and just be like fuck it,
I need this.
- Wow.
(laughing)
- I deserve this.
- I'm going to be able to
join the Frappuccino cult
and like, blend in and I
don't have to drink coffee.
Great
Thank you.
(door opening)
Chelsea, look what I got.
(soothing music)
- This is a huge straw.